begin by thanking everyone again
for your patience and for the sacrifices
that
you've been making businesses pubs
restaurants that have been waiting to
welcome customers back through their
doors grandparents who have gone for
months
without seeing their grandchildren
weddings postponed
funerals sadly constrained and religious
festivals such as
eid yet again facing restrictions
and i want to thank you particularly
because your efforts
have so visibly paid off giving us the
time to vaccinate
more than two-thirds of all adults
across the uk
with more than one-third nearly 18
million people
also receiving their second dose
and thereby unquestionably saving
many lives and so it's precisely because
of your efforts
that i can confirm today that we've met
our four tests for further easing the
lockdown
in england and chris will uh run through
the details
in a minute but with deaths and
hospitalizations at their lowest level
since last july
uh the and the uk's four chief medical
officers
today agreeing a reduction in the alert
level
the data now support moving to step
three in england from next monday the
17th
of may this means the rule of six or two
households that is applied
outdoors will now apply indoors
and the limit for outdoor meetings will
increase to 30
from next monday you'll be able to sit
inside a pub and inside
a restaurant you'll be able to go to the
cinema and children will be able to use
indoor play areas we're reopening
hostels
hotels bmbs we'll reopen the doors to
our
theaters concert halls and business
conference centres we'll unlock the
turnstiles
of our sports stadia subject to capacity
limits and
from next week everyone will be able to
travel
within britain and stay overnight
meaning schools will also be able
to organize trips with overnight stays
we will no longer require face coverings
in classrooms
or for students in communal areas in
secondary schools and
colleges all remaining university
students
will be able to return to in-person
teaching
where they should be tested twice a week
we will increase the number of named
visitors for those in care homes from
two to five
and residents will have greater freedoms
to leave their home
without having to isolate on their
return
this unlocking amounts to a very
considerable step on the road back
to normality and i am confident that we
will be able
to go further subject to the impact of
step three on the data
we remain on track to move to step four
on the 21st of june and to give
business more time to prepare we'll be
saying more
later this month about exactly what the
world will look like and what role there
could be
if any for certification and social
distancing
and today we're taking a step towards
that moment
when we learn to live responsibly with
kovid
when we cease eventually to rely on
detailed government edicts and
make our own decisions based on the best
scientific advice about
how to protect our families and those
around us
so from next monday we're updating the
guidance
on close contact between friends and
family
setting out the risks for everyone to
make
their own choices this doesn't mean we
can suddenly
throw caution to the winds in fact
more than a year into this pandemic we
all know
that close contact such as hugging is a
direct way
of transmitting this disease so i urge
you
to think about the vulnerability of your
loved ones
whether they've had a vaccine one or two
doses
and whether there has been time for that
vaccine
to take effect remember
outdoors is always safer than indoors
and if you're meeting indoors remember
to open a window
and let in the fresh air keep getting
tested regularly
even if you don't have symptoms so you
don't spread the virus
without knowing it and whatever you
decide
i must ask you to continue to follow
social distancing
when not with friends and family
including in workplaces
shops pubs restaurants
and other settings we only have to look
at the very sad situation
in other countries to see the lethal
potential still
of this virus and we must continue to
fight the spread of variants
here in the uk while we have
no evidence yet to believe that these
variants
are completely vaccine resistant we must
remain vigilant so
please remember hands face space
and fresh air and as we mark
mental health awareness week perhaps
also
take a moment to check in on friends and
family
and see how they are doing after all
that we have been through
together or if you're struggling
yourself
get the support that you need
today we are announcing
the single biggest step on our roadmap
and it will allow us to do many of the
things
that we've yearned to do for a long time
so let's protect these games by
continuing
to exercise caution and common sense
thank you and over to chris thank you
prime minister
um the ministers actually set out four
tests for moving between the stages
and i just like to lay out the data
behind each of these tests first slide
please
so the first test was that the vaccine
deployment program
continues successfully and i think it's
very clear
to everybody in uh the uk that this has
uh been very successful a steady rollout
for people for their first vaccinations
so we now have
just over two-thirds of people have had
a first vaccine
in terms of adults and just over
a third of adults have had a second
vaccine already
starting with the most vulnerable and
this continues thanks to the
extraordinary efforts of the nhs
next slide please the second test was
that evidence continues to show
that vaccines are sufficiently effective
at reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated there
were original
trial data we now have uh very clear
data from real world settings
and some of that was published further
data was published
by public health england uh today and
this shows that
there is somewhere between a 55 and 70
percent reduction
in terms of symptomatic disease for
people who've had a first vaccine
around a 75 to 85 percent reduction
in terms of hospitalization and
uh a round a 75 to 80 reduction
in the chance of someone dying after
they've had the first vaccine
we also have data particularly from the
pfizer
uh vaccine it's accumulating for a zed
which we started to roll out
slightly later demonstrating that the
second dose
significantly further increases the
protection
so that over 90 percent and possibly
over 95 percent
of people protection for people from
death if they have that vaccine so this
is
undoubtedly this test has been met
next slide please there is however an
important
point to make on this and that is that
we know that the mortality the chance of
dying and the chance of having severe
disease
is much more weighted towards people who
are older
or have pre-existing health conditions
and what in
on the left hand side of this graph what
we have is over the period of this
pandemic
the total number of people who have
sadly died of kovid
in england and what you can see is the
red line demonstrates
the age group to which we've got so the
majority of people in every age band
over the age of 40
have now had a first vaccine and a
significant proportion of those at the
top end of this have had a second
booster dose they have got a lot of
protection but remembering
this protection is not 100 but on the
right what you see is the total number
of people
who actually have cases of kovid and
what this
shows is that a substantial proportion
of the people who catch kovid
and some of whom will get significant
long-term problems themselves
but also who transmits kovid have not
yet been valid this is
a very positive thing that a loss of
protection
to those who most vulnerable but
additionally it makes clear
why it is that if we go too fast at this
stage when things have gone so well
thanks to the
efforts of the entire population that
there is a risk of significant spread
amongst those in the younger age groups
next slide please the third test is that
infection rates do not risk
a surge in hospitalizations that would
put unsustainable pressure on the nhs
and as the prime minister has said the
view of all the
chief medical officers for england
scotland wales and northern ireland
and of the medical director of the nhs
based on advice from jbc
is not only that rates in hospital are
very low which
we can see in this graph showing there's
been a steady decline and the number of
people who've dying from covid
is now very small indeed thankfully
in the uk but that
we do not think there is a likelihood in
the next period
after this uh upsurge of seeing a
significant increase
in pressure on the nhs although some
increase in transmission
should be assumed as a result of the
opening up that the prime minister has
has laid out next slide please
the final test and in a way the most
difficult test
is the assessment of the risk from
variance of concern these are
new variants of kovid which might be one
or other or both of either more
transmissible
than existing ones and everyone in the
country will remember that when the b117
variant
first started emerging in kent it then
spread incredibly fast so more
transmissible ones are potentially a
problem
or ones which could cause problems with
vaccination
and we do have uh some confidence
that the vaccines we have provides a
reasonable degree of protection
from severe disease but that can be
reduced with
some of the existing variants including
the one
b1351 first described in south africa uh
but others could emerge
or we might get more transmissible ones
and we have uh
a concern at the moment about a variant
uh called b1617.2 rather snappy uh
name uh first described from india and
this uh is actually spreading from very
small amounts
uh but it is beginning to spread in
certain parts of the country
and we need to keep quite a close eye on
this so the point about this is
the threats are significantly reduced
but there are still
some uh residual issues that we need to
keep a very close eye on and therefore
we need to go carefully
and steadily as the prime minister has
said
thanks very much chris uh patrick
anything to add at this at this stage
then let's go to
members of the public and from york
what proportion of recent daily
infections
is found to come from variants of
concern other than the kent variant
chris i think i'm going to pass that one
to
to you uh yes the um the numbers in
terms of actually how many there are
are were in the last slide so i think
people may want to look at the exact
numbers
the proportions at the moment are less
than five percent uh our variants
are uh which are the um not the b117 the
uh
kent variant which is the dominant one
in the uk but
uh that's changing the whole time most
of them are currently relatively stable
and not increasing at a great rate
the one that is uh slightly concerning
us in terms of increasing as a
proportion
uh is the the variant uh which has been
described from india
and that is in certain parts of the uk
and that does appear to be increasing
but from very low levels
over the last uh two weeks
thanks very much anne uh thank you chris
francis from lincoln
with the road map set to open up for
physical
contact e.g hugs from the 17th of may
how are you planning to protect the
unvaccinated
under 40s teachers and support staff who
will undoubtedly feel the consequences
of this
well francis thank you very much and i
know there's going to be a lot of people
thinking about the uh the
guidance on hugging and how if at all
they should
uh they should respond and i would i
would say that people
as i said in my earlier remarks people
should
obviously you should you should do it if
you think it's appropriate if you think
uh there's uh the risks are very very
low
but you should exercise care and common
sense and clearly
uh with unvaccinated people
there must be a greater risk of
transmission
than those who have had vaccination but
there again
don't forget francis that even with two
doses of the vaccine although you will
be
at much less risk of uh of death or of
hospitalization
uh there is still a risk of of
transmission even though it's greatly
reduced so
basically uh francis it's up to all of
us
to exercise common sense and and caution
in the way we
we do it uh let's go to hugh pym of the
bbc
thank you prime minister is it possible
that you might even bring
forward the june the 21st date for the
final stage of the
road map and the lifting of all legal
restrictions or will you definitely
stick to that as the earliest possible
time
hugh i i think it's very important that
we
should proceed uh cautiously
uh but as i as i've said many times now
uh hopefully irreversibly and the the
secret of the
success that we've had so far i think
has been that we have been guided by the
the data and we've given time to see the
effect of each successive
stage on the on the roadmap so from uh
march the 6th to april the 12th and then
april the 12th to may the 17th and then
on to
june the 21st we've given ourselves a
breathing space
what's happening today or what's
happening on monday the 17th
everybody should understand is a very
considerable unlocking
and uh there will be a lot of
uh of extra movement a lot of uh a lot
of extra
uh contact that's just inevitable from
what's happening we think it's prudent
we think we can
we can do it but it's got to be done in
a in a way that's
uh that's cautious and i think we'll
want to have time to
to see the effect you've heard what
chris has said about the presence of the
uh of the indian variant and other
variants
we've just got to monitor these things
as we go along and
i think what business would want to see
uh
getting ready for the 21st is as much
certainty
about that as possible and and that's
what we we aim to deliver
thank you very much hugh romelly weeks
of itv
prime minister now you're telling people
to use their own judgment
on hugging given that it is a
significant factor in the spread of
kobit are you expecting people to be
extremely cautious about who
and how often they hug if i can also ask
who you're looking forward to hugging
and last week you said there was a good
chance we could scrap
social distancing rules altogether after
june the 21st
the scientists doing the modeling
suggests we have no idea what will
happen if that is done
would that really be a wise move in that
case
uh thanks very much romilly well i i
just repeat what i said i think
and whoever i uh hug i can assure you
will be done with caution and
uh and restraint uh i'm i'm not going to
to
you know act it out now uh but uh i
think we all know
uh what what we mean it's it's about
basic uh common sense and when it comes
to um
uh social distancing from from june the
21st
um i i look at the data very carefully
and i i think at the moment
it looks to me as though we may we may
be able
to dispense with the one meter plus rule
that's not yet decided it's not yet
clear we'll have to
we'll have to wait and see but it's it's
by being prudent
and being cautious that we've been able
to make the the progress that
that we have as i say we'll be saying
more to everybody more to business
uh to give everybody as much clarity as
we can about how they should prepare
uh by the end of this month getting
ready for for june the 21st
uh crystal patrick anything you want to
add to on the on the great hugging uh
i'll i'll answer on on the question
about the
post june the 21st and what the modelers
have done
is made an assumption the stump still
some residual reduction
in transmission and that's due to a
number of things
um hopefully better ventilation
there'll still be people who are working
from home who can work from home
and it's right for their business to do
so there will be behaviors that will all
demonstrate which means that contacts
probably won't be back
to pre-pandemic levels so on average
pre-pandemic
adults and children roughly 11 contacts
per day
currently it's down to about four or so
for adults so it will probably remain
down for a while to come it's important
that we continue to
isolate if positive or with symptoms
that's really
really important to reduce the number of
people out in circulation
who are um potentially able to pass the
virus on
and then you know there may be other
things as well required in certain
circumstances and it may be
you know as winter comes and uh if rates
went up again
things like um covering face coverings
on transport might be necessary but this
is that first tranche of things that
first group of things that are really
important in terms of
keeping down the levels and those aren't
big impositions on any of us that a what
we're going to do probably in terms of
how we interact with each other
and b things like the ventilation the
ability to still
stay working from home if it's
appropriate to do so
thanks very much romney uh tom newton
done times radio
thank you prime minister uh question to
all three of you
if i may i'm working from home i know
you're gonna give business time to pray
you said that but so that they can start
to think about it now
is working from home going to go as
terms of guidance on june the 21st
or should people be thinking about that
continuing through the summer
through the autumn potentially even uh
through christmas and
prime minister uh you won't say who
you'll hug first but who will you shake
hands with first and when are you going
to
start shaking hands again you were one
of the last to stop shaking hands maybe
who are you going to shake hands with
when you're allowed to where will that
be
uh tom on all that we're going to be
giving
as i said uh i i mean i don't want to be
a you know uh
uh i don't know your question's a very
good one but i think we're gonna
wait and give you uh more detail and
more guidance about exactly what we
mean by the end of uh of social
distancing
uh later this month i'm optimistic
that things will uh get you know back
much closer
to normality let me put it like that but
clearly people
are going to continue to want to
exercise their own judgment their own
discretion uh
for for a long while to come um that's
but uh
you you'll hear a lot more by the end of
this month about exactly what
the world after june the 21st is going
to look like at the moment
i'm feeling very positive about it but
we've got to be we've got to be guided
by the data
i need to add on that thank you very
much jason groves daily mail
hi thanks prime minister um can i say
scientists given the
uh excellent data we're getting on the
uh
the success of the vaccines could this
now potentially
be the last lockdown that we see
borrowing uh the emergence of any
terrible new variant uh and prime
minister uh can i just pick you up
on that uh last point you you've you've
said in the past
uh that you would like to see uh
people back at their desks at the end of
all this is that
is that how you see the future do you
think people can work as effectively
there or
or is working from home got a big part
to play in the future still
um last lockdown to chris patrick well
i mean as the prime minister said this
is a big step that's being taken now
step three lots of things are starting
up again
over the next month there'll be many
more people vaccinated so
the balance is between opening up and
getting enough people vaccinated to be
protected so it's important that we
don't get out of step with that and go
ahead of ourselves
i think things are really pointed in the
right direction we'll have a much
clearer idea of
the effects of step three in mid-june so
we'll know what effect that's had
but everything is pointed in the
direction that the vaccines are
producing very effective
reduction in hospitalizations and death
as chris has said
we know that they're also reducing
onward transmission
all of that points to this now being a
much smoother path it points to
a lower increase than you might
otherwise have expected with another
wave
and things you know if they carry on
without variants are definitely pointed
in the right direction
yeah and jason on your um
uh your point about what's the world
gonna look like are people gonna get
back to work do we want people to get
back to work well
i just remember uh when i was when i was
running tf i think i made this point
before observing a sudden a sort of
paradox of
of of transport which is that the more
people can
communicate remotely with brilliant uh
electronic devices the
the more able they are to to meet other
people
over the internet or uh through the
ether
the more reasons they actually find
to meet face to face and uh
i i'm pretty certain and i know this is
contested but i'm pretty certain that
eventually
uh our town centers are gonna be uh our
city centers are gonna be full of bustle
uh full of people uh wanting to interact
again in the way that they always have
done
now i might be i might be mistaken in
that belief
but uh i've a long experience of
watching the way uh great metropolises
operate um leads me to suppose that that
is what will
uh what will happen uh said pain of the
financial times
thank you very much prime minister and
what you've announced today
suggests that the pandemic is beginning
to become under control
and we may be past the worst of the
crisis
do you where do you think it would be
reasonable and not irresponsible then
for scotland to hold a second
independence referendum
and for professor witty and your side
showed that the number of cases of the
indian variant have doubled
in the last week are you at all
concerned this could destabilize the eat
lockdown easing plans and could lead to
a further lockdown in the autumn
well seb on your first point i had good
conversations with all the
uh heads of the devolved administrations
and
uh i can tell you everybody was resolved
that the number one priority for
uh the whole of the uk was to uh build
back better
come out of the crater virus pandemic
and build that better together
um on the indian variant in fact there
are currently three engine variants but
the one that we're worried about at the
moment in the uk is the six one seven
point two
um uh it is it has gone up very sharply
and i think that's a reason for us
uh to be very careful about it and
there's a lot of work being done by
public health england
uh to try and delineate where it is and
to work out ways we by testing and
uh isolation we can get that on top of
uh to
get on top of the curve of that india
has also gone into
the red list which means that new people
coming in would have been significantly
uh reduced but i think what you you know
in answer to both your question and to
the previous one
what we know is with all the variants
that things can come out of a blue sky
uh you're not expecting it and then
something happened that happened uh
obviously with the b117
and that has happened to india uh with
this uh variant as well
so i think we would be very improving to
say
it is impossible i think at this point
in time
i think our view is that this is a
highly transmissible variant
at least as transmissible as the b117
variant
it is possible it is more transmissible
but we'll have to see
uh at this point in time uh at the
at this point in time our view is it is
less
likely to be uh able to escape
vaccination
than some of the other variants because
they're from one but the data are not
properly in there so i think it is you
know we need to be
cautious until we've seen clear data
that give us an answer one way or the
other
that the reason i've given that as a
relatively technical answer is of course
we don't
know whether this is going to cause
significant problems in the autumn the
way to deal with that is
identify the cases which have been
happening isolate where we can
which is also happening get through the
rest of the vaccination program
and ensure that we have the capacity to
pick these up
and also to re-vaccinate as necessary
when the autumn comes
the final point on this is the way to
prevent
minimize the number of variants that
circulate is obviously get on top of
this as a global problem
and that's something that all of us are
absolutely determined to uh support
thanks very much seb uh adam bienkov of
business insider
prime minister you were on record as
opposing the last labor government's
plans
for compulsory photo id cards which you
described as a recipe for tyranny and
oppression
why therefore you're now planning to
bring forward in the queen's speech
legislation which will force
all voters to carry photo id in order to
vote and given the fact that there was
just a single conviction in the entire
country for in-person voter fault at the
last general election
and given the studies show that labour
voters are much less likely to possess
photo id
conservative voters what do you say to
people who suggest this is median
attempt to suppress the votes of people
who may not vote for the conservative
party uh
adam i would say that was complete
nonsense and
what we want to do is to
protect democracy the transparency and
the integrity of the electoral
process and i don't think it's
unreasonable to ask
first-time voters to produce some
evidence of
of identity so that's the that's the
reason
okay everybody thank you very much
indeed thank you
you